si observamos la mayoría de las cosas
si pasamos de un estado líquido donde
las cosas literalmente fluyen las
moléculas se mueven a un estado sólido
donde las cosas son más rígidas
normalmente tenemos algo que se vuelve
más denso entonces el estado líquido es
menos denso menos denso y el estado
sólido es más denso más denso pero
pensemos qué ocurriría si el agua fuera
como la mayoría de las cosas imaginemos
un lugar con agua esta es la tierra y
todo lo demás es agua como en esta
imagen y supongamos que está muy frío el
aire es extremadamente frío podemos
decir que se encuentra por debajo de la
temperatura de congelación del agua
entonces lo que ocurrirá es que el agua
que tenemos aquí arriba se congelará la
superficie se congela pero si el hielo
fuera más denso si el agua sólida fuera
más densa que el agua líquida
bueno esta agua congelada se podría
hundir el hielo se hundiría y se
quedaría en el fondo y después
nuevamente el agua que tendríamos arriba
se congelaría y si esto fuera más denso
se hundiría y se quedaría en el fondo
así este proceso se estaría repitiendo
hasta que eventualmente toda el agua del
lago se congelará y fuera sólida se
congelaría pero imagínense esto no sería
bueno para los animales que viven en el
agua por ejemplo vamos a poner un pez
los peces también se congelaría y la
mayoría de los seres vivos bueno existen
unos pocos organismos simples que pueden
sobrevivir congelados pero la mayoría de
los seres vivos moriría por eso esto no
sería un buen ambiente para los animales
que viven aquí e incluso para que ocurra
la biología pero lo curioso sobre el
agua es que nos sigue este patrón miren
cuando hablamos del agua cuando hablamos
de la
si pasamos del estado líquido si pasamos
de agua líquida a hielo sólido a sólido
en realidad esto es menos denso vamos a
poner esto es menos denso esta es la
razón por la que el hielo flota esto es
más denso más denso y esto es menos
denso pero para analizar por qué pasa
eso regresemos a los puentes de
hidrógeno en los vídeos anteriores vimos
que lo pondré todo de un solo color
oxígeno hidrógeno hidrógeno supongamos
que esto está en estado líquido
aquí tenemos agua líquida entonces
tenemos oxígeno hidrógeno e hidrógeno y
por acá tenemos oxígeno hidrógeno e
hidrógeno ya hemos hablado muchas veces
de que aquí tenemos cargas parciales
negativas lejos de los hidrógenos
parcial negativa porque el oxígeno es
muy electro negativo y por acá tenemos
cargas parciales positivas en los
hidrógenos cargas parciales positivas en
los hidrógenos entonces como las cargas
parciales negativas y las cargas
parciales positivas se atraen a esto se
le conoce como puentes de hidrógeno
ahora en el estado líquido hay
suficiente energía temperatura que en
realidad es la energía cinética promedio
que estas moléculas tienen para moverse
rompiendo y reformando los puentes de
hidrógeno una y otra vez todo está
fluyendo y tienen suficiente energía
para empujarse más de cerca unas de
otras incluso más cerca de lo que
determinarían los puentes de hidrógeno a
veces están más cerca a veces están más
lejos y se van empujando pero conforme
todo se va enfriando conforme esto se
enfría y perdemos calor
las moléculas ya no tienen la energía
cinética para estar tan cerca y
empujarse entre ellas se forma una
estructura que es muy parecida a una red
se ve así oxígeno hidrógeno hidrógeno
oxígeno hidrógeno hidrógeno oxígeno
hidrógeno hidrógeno aquí las moléculas
se encuentran lejos de las otras porque
no tienen la energía cinética para
seguir rompiendo y reformando estos
puentes de hidrógeno ni para empujarse
entre ellas así que se forma una
estructura en red por acá podemos tener
otro oxígeno obviamente lo estoy
dibujando en dos dimensiones pero
sabemos que el hielo y muchas cosas que
hay en nuestra realidad están en tres
dimensiones pero espero que esto les dé
una idea y tenemos estos puentes de
hidrógeno estos puentes de hidrógeno no
se mueven pero los electrones se siguen
moviendo aún tenemos una carga
y al positiva aquí y una carga parcial
negativa acá pero no hay suficiente
energía cinética para que las moléculas
se empujen y estén más cerca no pueda
influir una con respecto a la otra
entonces aquí tenemos hielo
esta es agua sólida hielo es menos denso
y es por eso que el hielo flota es por
eso que los icebergs flotan y también
que los lagos se ven así solo la
superficie se congela pero hay agua
fluyendo abajo
de hecho el hielo de la superficie
protege al agua que hay abajo imagínense
el hielo protege para que el agua no se
siga congelando así es como los animales
se siguen moviendo y logran pasar el
invierno y una vez que todo se derrite
llegamos a la primavera y el verano